hey guys welcome back to another video
and before we get started I just want to
say that if you checked my yesterday's
video and you want it to download the
amino app I forgot to put the links in
the description I super-duper apologize
about that but they are in the
description there you can click the card
in the top right to be immediately taken
to that video and you can go down the
description and download it for yourself
but that's only if you did enjoy that
app but anyway
let's get started so first up I'm going
to have two more videos after this yeah
two more so it's three in one day I
rarely upload twice in one week let
alone three in one day so leave a like
just for the just for the grind that I'd
be doing for the next couple hours here
so the two new other videos today's is
going to be about the characters the
next one is going to be about the maps
and then the one after that is going to
be sifting through the 22 page patch
notes of 1.11 so those are going to be
out in the next hour - hopefully I can
get that out today but like I said it's
going to be characters Maps than the
patches but today is going to be about
the characters so let's get started
again so first off the new weekly
content is new mythic outfits along with
the new effect as well which I showed
you right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
so those look pretty flashy I think the
samurai though best personally have the
best one those are going to be costing
you 15,000 steel if you choose to buy
those there is a play with a dev event
at tomorrow at 3:30 p.m. est I'm PC
where the devs bulb basically played
Dominion all day so if you do have a PC
and you're with you know if you're on
that time go for it you might play some
of the devs will have the Ubisoft logo
so hopefully you enjoy that next up they
showed the trailers for each of the
characters so I'll play those videos for
you right now but once those are done
I'm going to show you some of the
screenshots of the characters armor
weapons and ornaments that they set they
also showed us as well and that'll be
after the video and hopefully you guys
will like it that's going to be the end
of it though so once I show that I'll
show them I'll show the ornaments
weapons and armor with some music in the
background for you guys to enjoy and
that'll be it like I said though guys if
you did enjoy it like the video
especially for this trip will upload
subscribe for more content to be on the
lookout for future videos today my most
recent up will be at the end of the
video if you want to check that out we
talked about the Highlander moveset that
got leaked so you do not want to miss
that but anyway I'll stop wasting your
time and I hope you guys enjoy it and
I'll see you in the next video peace out
like the rocks that break the waves
Highlanders have weathered many storms
ancient alliances kept their land safe
but that fools have come to you they
join our war out of obligation but they
are not to be underestimated their claim
war is the heavier chord ever wielded it
can cut down even the most Harvard
warrior the elements battering their
lands have made them strong war has made
them deadly
[Music]
[Music]
the roar of the crowd can be
intoxicating it can give you the edge
you need to defeat an opponent you can
also seal your fate
should you lose sleep
the arena is not a battlefield the
thrill of the fight has waned but how
will they fare in all-out war gladiators
have risen the ranks of fighters and
have run out of challengers with their
Trident and shield they charge into the
fray
their armor minimal and their bravado
staggering it is now time for gladiators
to fight for something greater than
themselves
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]